hi everyone
as some of you may know but others will
not
it's been a long while since i put up
any new content
on this youtube channel i've been
suffering from
impaired health severely impaired health
as a consequence of benzodiazepine use
for anxiety or more accurately from a
combination of
using that medication and then ceasing
its use
once i realized it was dangerous
that's put me in and out of hospitals
for much of the last year in
connecticut in the united states in
toronto
in canada in moscow in russia
and in belgrade serbia as
my family searched for specialists who
could aid me in the severe
post-use withdrawal and
neurological damage related consequences
of
both the benzodiazepine use and and its
cessation
um i started taking it in 2016
2017 early 2017
according to the prescribed
recommendations and really never give it
a second thought
uh that was a mistake uh to say the
least
anyways i've learned some things during
that trying time i suppose or at least
i've
i can tell you what kept me going during
what was certainly the worst period of
my life
family that's for sure
friends and the work i was able to
continue doing as i was able to continue
writing
something that i'll talk about
probably within the next month my family
my wife tammy my son julian and his wife
julian and my daughter
michaela and her husband andre have been
of inestimable value to me
and provided me with tremendous support
during this period
michaela and andre accompanied me to
russia and to serbia both of those
episodes were extremely grueling and
lasted for months
but i'm alive and i have plans for the
future
i want to thank those people from the
bottom of my heart
my extended family and friends whom i
will name elsewhere
went above and beyond the call of duty
in my estimation i
certainly not convinced that i would
have the character to
provide to any one of them what they
provided to me
so that was a humbling lesson i suppose
um my work
this sort of work although it was all
writing and not video production was
also
extremely useful because i could sustain
myself
by producing and then culling through
thoughts that were helpful despite my
anguish
i suppose and my lack of hope for the
future
um hopefully
we'll see but hopefully much of that is
behind me and i can
return to something resembling a normal
life
i can tell you what my plans are for
video production at least for the next
while
i completed a biblical series
devoted to genesis in fall of 2017 and
that has proved
very popular i it's a strange word to
use for a lecture series like that
um i'm going to start working on
the next book in the old testament which
is
exodus but in that will take a while but
in the interim
i think i'm going to produce videos
devoted to proverbs
the book of wisdom essentially or a book
of wisdom
you've all heard no doubt that wisdom is
proverbial is that or that there's such
a thing as proverbial wisdom and
that phrase
stems from the book of proverbs which
are
single sentence aphorisms imparting
some truth i think the analysis of those
which can be done in a relatively short
period of time
will prove of benefit to me and perhaps
to those who
are inclined to watch or listen to my
analysis
um i would also like to
thank all of you for
continuing to support my work
i have far more followers on youtube and
instagram
and twitter for that matter and then i
did
before i became ill and my book has sold
very well
in in multiple languages and that's
really amazing and remarkable and
i hope that what i produce in the
future will
that people will find it of
equal or greater utility that's an
ambitious hope given how much
attention what i've produced before has
garnered but
it still seems appropriate an
appropriate goal for
my upcoming activities i guess i could
let you all know as well that
we've put together this is an initiative
that was spearheaded by
michaela and andre we've put together
the ability to translate the youtube
lectures into
a variety of languages i think it's six
at the moment six will be ruled out over
the next few months
professionally translated dubbed because
our analysis indicated that in most of
these markets dubbed
videos are preferred to subtitle videos
and so
that will provide the opportunity for
the ideas i've been developing
many of which i have derived from other
sources
to be sure to
have an impact beyond the english
language speaking world there seems to
be
some desire for that um
my book my last book 12 rules for life
sold 300 000 copies in south korea for
example which
very much surprised me because i wasn't
sure that
the ideas well first were translatable
but were going to be
acceptable uh in a culture with
such a different developmental
background
anyways i'm not going to make this a
long video
i wanted to tell you that i'm back in
toronto that i'm
in much better health although it's
still severely impaired especially in
the morning
but i can work again and i really want
to
and that to let you know that with god's
grace
and mercy um i'll be able to
start generating original material once
again and
pick up where i left off
thank you very much and
well thank you very much is probably
sufficient
bye